good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to another session of the
Reuters forum in fact tonight is the
fourth in our series of seven panel
debates this year tonight's topic is
carrots and sticks uses and misuses of
American aid and sanctions I want to
remind you that we will not be meeting
for another per month we've got spring
break and then a holiday and so our next
meeting will be on April 10th but don't
forget about it it's only a month away
our topic then we'll be immigration
backlash labor migration and crisis and
we will have another stellar panel for
you but tonight's panel is especially
important and I'd like to introduce
immediately our moderator for tonight's
show dr. Peter Marie who is a regular
here at the Reuters form our expert on
trade who comes back every year this
year is topic is somewhat different dr.
Mursi is a professor at the University
of Maryland and he has also recently
been a senior fellow at the economic
strategy Institute so Peter I turn the
show over to you well I guess the forms
what 13 years old 12th year this is my
11th appearance they had they had one
off year tonight our subject is carrots
and sticks the uses and misuses of
American aid and sanctions both aidan
sanctions are deeply embedded in our
foreign policy both our political and
security policy and our economic policy
and they are employed to reinforce and
support all aspects of our foreign
policy objectives they are embedded in
international agreements such as the
agreements that the World Trade
Organization administers the
international labour office administers
regarding workers rights and so forth a
broadly speaking our foreign policy has
two sets of goals one is a
American security the security of our
territory are persons both here and when
they are abroad and of our businesses in
addition an important aspect of American
foreign policy is the projection of
American values we as much as any
society promote human rights the rule of
law and frankly market capitalism
because after all America is the home of
the market and and that is an important
aspect of our foreign policy whether
Republicans or Democrats are in is
promoting open markets and and trade and
things of that nature and we've talked
about that in past years at times these
balancing these objectives is it's
difficult for the casual observer to
seek and say well gee how can human
rights be an American objective if we're
supporting a dictator in Latin America
the answer is for security reasons there
are trade-offs likewise we don't always
apply sanctions in an even-handed and a
consistent way why some people are more
important than others and some people we
can get better results from in different
ways than others in all of this there is
a significant opportunity for aid to be
misused for it to be offered in with
promises that that are not fulfilled in
terms of economic development or social
progress there are opportunities for
sanctions to be misused too heavily
applied in some places without any
purpose for that maybe only to make
domestic political interest feel well in
all of this it is hard to draw a
consistent theme but we have free
panelists with us tonight whose purpose
it is to do that and since as you can
read they are very accomplished
individuals I'm sure they will lead us
from this intellectual quagmire into a
more orderly and reason space by the
hour of 730 p.m. you have the
biographies of two of them in front of
so only speak briefly about them and our
third panelist Patrick Cronin was taken
ill this morning and has sent James clad
to fill in and I'll tell you a little
bit more about him our first panelist is
probably the panelists that is best
known to you he is james Fallows the
Atlantic Monthly national correspondent
sigh I doubt that there is anybody in
this room who has not read james Fallows
he's the author of many books in
addition to his work at Atlantic
including breaking the news how the
media undermines American democracy and
he writes for the industry standard
slate in the New York Review of Books
our second panelist is James Birkeland
who has had an enormously successful and
distinguished career in investment
banking most recently he is with USB
Warburg LLC which was a which acquired
dillon read and company of which he was
the chairman and chief executive officer
you have all of that in front of you but
let me point out that mr. Birkeland has
found much time for public service for
service that aids the community and so
forth he is chairman of the Polish
Enterprise Fund he is chairman of the
International executive Services
Corporation and the Watson Institute for
International Affairs and finally we
have with us James clad who was just
appointed to the administration as a
senior counselor in a ID and the State
Department with regard to foreign aid
and u.s. foreign policy he just left
Georgetown University where he had a
endowed research professorship the henry
luce foundation research professorship
of South and Southeast Asian Studies in
recent years he has held senior
positions at carnegie endowment and the
Far East far eastern economic review I
can tell you that mr. clad is one of the
most knowledgeable people in America on
the Far East and Asia and he has
traveled there extensively and
his views are always worth listening to
so with that set it is my pleasure to
introduce first mr. fallows
thank you very much for your gracious
introduction thank you all for coming
out this evening the challenge given to
each of the panelist in the opening
remarks is to lay out a layout a
coherent view of the subject in six to
eight minutes this challenge is probably
less daunting for me than some of the
others because i am not an actual expert
on this subject i have spent a fair
amount of time reporting overseas and
i've spent some time writing about the
u.s. relationship for the rest of the
world but because of my particular
informed amateur as opposed to involved
specialist view i'm going to suggest a
way just a few large ways to start
thinking about this question of how the
u.s. uses both positive and negative
economic tools to get its way in the
world and that will come to a conclusion
that at least for me was surprising to
come to when i started thinking about
that so that's that's my plan for the
next few moments seems to me the
question we're thinking about in a broad
sense is the relationship between the
economic strength of the united states
which is at the moment its second
greatest area of relative strength in
the world its greatest area of relative
strength in the world is of course its
military monopoly where it now it will
within three years spend more money on
the military than the rest of the world
combined now spends more money in the
next 20 countries combined so our first
area of comparative advantage is
military but our second area of
comparative advantage is our economic
strength the question is how we link
that great power the ability to invest
the ability to consume of this economy
the ability to create with other
non-economic goals this nation
collectively and its people individually
may have for the world some of those
goals may be positive in the outside
world economic development advancement
of human rights advancement of
intellectual understanding advancement
of racial understanding advancement of
gender parity etc some of those goals
may be negative they may be discouraging
the drug trade discouraging terrorism
punishing nations for threats to our
security etc those goals may be acute in
certain times for example in the current
anti-terrorism war effort of getting
companies the countries to play ball
with us in the short term to give us
landing rights for our airplane
to give us a transit rights for our
troops or those goals may be chronic
they may be part of a cold war like
effort to deal with a rival world system
they may be long-term efforts on the
environment to encourage countries to
treat their natural resources in a
different way long-term efforts on human
rights etc etc so the question again is
how these varied non-economic interest
positive and negative chronic and acute
can be advanced by the great economic
powers of the US as disposal now it
seems to me that most times when the
government acts on this printable and
when it's politicians think about it
there are two sort of automatic pilot
ways of addressing the problem one of
the automatic pilot ways is to assume
that naturally and inevitably the
process of economic involvement business
relations capitalistic development will
inevitably were the course of time melt
away problems and bring nations into
concurred with each other this is the
bright side of the globalization
hypothesis that until say two or three
years ago was more or less was was was
common and it's the way that the US has
often talked about China over the last
20 years the last hundred years if you
do business with China than the other
country other problems will go away and
you see versions of this and other parts
of the world you see it in talking about
the Middle East if only there were more
economic development there there'd be
less bloodshed when I was reporting in
East Asia I should say that mr. clad was
kicked out of Malaysia for violating
their Official Secrets Act adjust the
time I moved in and we oh my almost
moved into your house there was another
one of your expelled colors whose house
I got so it was a great house and then
we were encouraged to leave in our own
course soon soon Iran soon enough but in
East Asia the idea was of u.s. foreign
policy has been encouraged normal
business enterprise and the cultural
differences the political differences
between East Asia and the Western
political system what will will go away
so that's one automatic pilot you don't
need to think about the effects because
business will take care of them itself
the second automatic pilot way of
thinking about this issue is to assume
that simply cutting off
business will have the desired effect
you can either do business and do good
or do no business and do good and either
one will get the result I will mention
the names Cuba Vietnam until a few years
ago North Korea South Africa Iraq in
varied ways those countries from the US
point of view were demonstrating the
principle that if you didn't do business
with someone you could get them to do
what what you wanted what I will suggest
to you very briefly is the evidence is
that neither of these automatic pilot
approaches really does the job on the
the idea of automatic globalization yes
I would assert that in the very long run
the run of perhaps centuries at least
decades it probably is true that a
modern functioning high tech business
system does lead to some common
political and cultural values but that
is a very long time if it meets John
Maynard Keynes as long term test of a
new long-term we're all dead because in
the medium term the Chinese in
particular have shown an ability to have
a functioning export-driven economy
without a western-style small d
democratic political system Burma or
Myanmar is shown that its own little way
the Balkans have shown it a different
way that you can have growth without
eliminating ethnic tensions and so you
know the sudden we can talk about later
on but I would suggest that the evidence
is against the idea that simple economic
engagement by itself will bring about
the kind of harmony we're looking for I
would suggest to the evidence is even
more grotesquely against the efficacy of
the don't doing business don't do
business with somebody a principle if
you look at the effect of embargoes and
sanctions in the long run it is very
very difficult to see them making a
difference I went to Vietnam as a
reporter several times during the
embargo stage it while they often
complained about the impact of US
embargo on their business development
they were doing fine with the Japanese
and the Canadians and others the
strategy towards Cuba I think when it
finally gets changed oh I guess when
Fidel Castro dies will be seen in
retrospect as the stupidest thing the US
has done for a very long time because it
had no beneficial effect North Korea we
haven't been able to
to bring to to bear so in a long-term
basis it doesn't really work in a short
term acute basis as a military tool
sanctions have really proven too slow to
leaky too difficult to enforce to do the
job the main exception complicating the
rule may be South Africa we'll save that
for later on so I would suggest that the
sanctions that don't do business
strategy is defensible mainly for how it
makes you feel if you feel cleaner not
doing business with Cuba on the one hand
South Africa on the other then that's a
reason for having the policy not the
alleged change in those in those
countries and that leads two to one sort
of subtopic year which is the
conditionality and rules put on foreign
aid whether the foreign aid rules
concern family planning whether you can
talk about it whether they are
opportunities for men and women and four
different tribal barriers my my instinct
my observation is that mainly affects
how we feel about it as opposed to
making a huge difference on the ground
this may be a subject for debate later
on what this brings me to my final 60
seconds is suggesting a sort of a
surprisingly moderate conclusion for me
at least surprising for me this makes me
think that the main way the u.s. can use
its economic might in the long term for
its non economic goals is through some
sort of modest structural agreements
that promote aims that we think worthy
in the long run for example NAFTA NAFTA
has a lot of complications for us
industries and Mexican industries alike
and say nothing of Canada but NAFTA will
probably promote in Mexico in the long
run I will assert values that we will
find to our national interest in Mexico
the Caribbean initiative the Caribbean
Basin initiative i think well in the
long run have a similar effect the
granddaddy of these all's is of course
the european union growing from the
European community showing how some kind
of modest regional economic arrangement
could promote some supra economic
interests and this will lead me to the
perhaps more offensive conclusion that
may be the most effective way the u.s.
can promote some non economic values
worldwide is too
thinking hard and creatively about the
World Trade Organization which is n to
trying to find ways to build into its
its operations the sorts of goals we
would like to stand for as a country and
as individuals that is my amateurs
overview I now turn it over to the
experts that was great James and it just
indicates that education can sometimes
be a barrier to understanding missed mr.
Birkeland would you care to take the
podium first of all Terry for thank you
very much for including me in the this
exciting session you can judge for my
background but I don't frequently
address groups of students and
particularly on subjects of such a great
proportion the gym I wouldn't disagree
with anything you've said I've been
engaged in in what you called private
sector aid for easily 15 years obviously
his professional life engage in venture
capital and so forth in this country and
President Bush asked me to chair the
first Enterprise Fund that was created
in this country for Poland and John
Whitehead shared the 14 hungry and from
that experience I derived a number of
conclusions and I would like to speak
more about process than about grand
schemes and if indeed we're going to
advance the objectives that we've been
talking about today process becomes very
very important and it isn't addressed
very often first of all I would say let
us look at our aid program our aid
program started out being a private
sector program it was the Marshall Plan
the pump for under Kennedy we had the
Peace Corps and the International
Service Corps were created at that time
both aimed private sector volunteer
organizations aim from the bottom up all
of those institutions including
and pushes initiative on the enterprise
fund which is aimed at investing in
private sector companies small companies
basically microloans medium-sized loans
so forth all those programs have been
remarkably effective but they're not
grand they're very specific and
regrettably they get lost the same thing
can be said on the sanctions front as
chairman of the Watson Institute we've
been doing a lot of studying about
sanctions probably among the leading
institutions engaged in that ghastly
arena someone told me that that in the
sanctions world Iraq was the equivalent
of Somalia in the terrorist world these
broad strokes that we make in the world
seldom have the effect we want so it's
Brown at Brown and Watson Institute
we've been working on smart sanctions
aiming them at the individuals and their
financial well-being for causing the
trouble well that's a worldwide problem
and they're doing work in Switzerland
with the UN and so forth but again it's
process so in my view the important
thing is when we're pursuing these grand
goals which are terribly important to
this country the process of how we
pursue them is very important and I
would suggest that with regard to a ID
for instance and all our aid programs
first of all they're meniscal I think
we're as a percentage of GNP one of the
lowest countries in that industrial
world in terms of the funding point one
percent of GNP it doesn't quite live up
to what we claim to be in the world when
we say we're in favour of democracy and
economic development so forth and we say
0.1% the second thing is that the people
of a ideal I deeply respect have been
struggling in a world that is so
overwhelmed with
immediacy and the demands of immediacy
that is very helpful very difficult for
them to unroll a program that will
sustain over a period of time the kinds
of objectives they're seeking the
primary objective I think on one hand in
a ID is to develop economies free
economies why because in free economies
you develop a middle class you develop a
group of stakeholders you develop a
civil society and ultimately all those
things are requisite to developing a
workable democracy so therefore there's
got to be an interest in that sort of
activity helping businessmen little
businessmen not big not world trade
organizations in the IT you know IBM and
so forth but rather working at the
bottom from the bottom up with volunteer
organizations that support those small
efforts which are conducted by people
who become in a very real sense
diplomats diplomats at the ground level
I see hope Gardner's here who is the
chief executive of international exact
series core and i'm proud to say that
since nineteen sixty-two you know
international executive service corps
has been engaged in that sort of thing
with volunteers helping small business
men all over the world well with the
overwhelming needs that are thrust upon
us whether they're anti terrorist or
humanitarian or health or whatever the
economic bottom up part of our activity
has really been dwarfed and in our view
it is the most effective part of what we
do abroad so I have a few suggestions
that I think based on the experience
that I've had and I have to say that I
have not been in government so obviously
I'm very humble in these suggestions
we must increase the funding in a ID for
foreign assistance we have to define
very carefully the role that we would
like the multinationals to pursue so
that they don't overlap each other and
can contaminate themselves in the
process as is the case presently with
the IMF and World Bank and then I
suggest that we separate out in our
planning and in our budgeting a private
efforts a private window where we're
trying to help economies through private
volunteer organizations such as the
Peace Corps the IES see the enterprise
funds and so forth from the bottom up
and we budget that and we don't let
anything invade that budget right now
it's not budgeted and it's residual
residual isn't very much if I could tell
you what we've accomplished in Poland
that would take me the rest of our time
here but it Poland is a vibrant vibrant
economy we've been lucky to dissipate in
it and I think we've had a vast effect
and we're now moving over into the
Ukraine the other side of that equation
is what I call demands that are made
upon us that we cannot resist and that's
the whole humanitarian seen that relates
to health that relates to disasters that
relates to terrorism and so forth but
we've got to keep that thing separate
from our proactive things the things
that we're trying to develop
economically in these countries that
evolve democracies the next thing I
think we have to do is to classify those
countries where we think we can have an
effect in terms of our economic policies
and those countries where basically
we're just trying to help out without
being able to really measure the result
regrettably a large portion of our aid
is directed to countries and through
governments where one has the question
and where whether any effectiveness is
achieved next I think we ought to focus
in our aie programs and volunteer
organizations and not paid consultants I
have witnessed what volunteers can do in
this world and the country is filled
with people who want to render service
and we're not encouraging them enough
Peace Corps is a wonderful example
internationally Vegas core is another
there's a financial advisor visor parka
for NGO that's been very effective next
I think we've got to have very clear
objectives and be able to measure them
certainly in the area of economic aid
and having said all that if we could
separate out the things that we budget
against the things that are forced upon
us by contingency we would have
accomplished a great deal we could tell
what we're doing with our aid much more
effectively Luo Tian today at this
particular point I don't believe anybody
in the United States can tell you how
much of our AI aid money is going to
private sector bottom up I don't think
it's definable one last point two last
points I believe there is a possibility
to develop what we call smart sanctions
sanctions that are targeted to deal with
people who are causing the trouble
rather than the people who are innocent
we're working on that at Watson the UN
is working on it it's a very delicate
question because you've got to trace
money all the way around the world
that's not so easy but we're working on
it and lastly I fully agree with you Jim
on the trade side I think the
initiatives that we have undertaken with
NAFTA etc
are to be encouraged I think the World
Trade Organization is a little too grand
for me to understand and produces so
many antibodies I wonder sometimes
whether its effectiveness isn't
overwhelmed so having said all that I
welcome this opportunity for a podium to
speak about something that it isn't
spoken about very often and that is the
private sector thank you it often makes
me wonder whether hearing presentations
like that whether we should move into a
world into the American Red Cross we
leave disaster to a privately managed
organization sometimes I wonder whether
we should do the same with aid finally
we will hear from James clack James
thank you Peter it's good to see jump
follows again we were reporting Asia in
the late 80s I used to wonder why when
he had impact on he wrote he'd be
offered another book contract when I had
impact I'd be thrown into jail it was an
interesting combination I'm glad to go
my house jump I think I recall it being
a wren tracked at the time I hope they
did a better deal for you I'm not only a
stand-in guide tonight for Patrick
Cronin who sends his apologies but I'm
also in a weird position because I'm I'm
halfway into the administration on
halfway not when I called my daughter is
a fourth-year student at Vassar and told
her I've been invited to join the
administration there was a hushed
silence the obligatory that's great dad
and then her voice went very low and she
said I didn't know you are a Republican
I found it an interesting opportunity to
both leave the Georgetown faculty and
come in to work with a number of people
who I respect to admire very much and
the American government and I want to
talk in the remaining time a little bit
about aid in foreign policy and tell you
a few things that may be useful to you
as you think out what your government's
doing in this area there was a feeling
by the people who are now in power that
under the last ministration aided become
an interesting grab bag of worthy
unfunded mandates a number of ideas that
expanded in the post-cold war
environment perhaps inevitably but it
become rather tenuous and let's say
detach from the mothership of our of our
overall foreign policy objectives and
some of the work that's going on now is
to try to deliver a policy and a program
that is a little bit more coherent with
our objectives and I don't want you to
think automatically aha this is
post-september 11th objectives it's some
kind of nice wraparound for an intensely
national security and counterterrorism
thrust it's not that way at all people
who work with secretary Powell or I
think often astonished at how much he
pays attention to issues not just the
AIDS pandemic around the world but to a
number of other issues that I think to
speak I think very nobly of a broad
consensus bipartisan consensus this
country has a lot of things to do out
there in the world let me talk quickly
about how much we give let me talk about
who gives it let me talk about how much
discretion we have with American
official development assistance a little
bit about objectives successes and
failures and what's coming up in the
next six months that's a lot of things
to try to do in the remaining time but
let's go through quickly the aid budgets
about 12 billion dollars a year most of
that is bilateral assistance
multilaterals nearly two billion go to
the World Bank in the Asian Development
Bank who gives it it's not only from a
ID these agency for international
development comes to the State
Department's with jealousy guards its
economic support funds ESF boy when you
go to Washington it's like
acronym mania and I find always like
getting it wrong and making a total fool
of myself at the interagency meetings
but never mind I'll learn Treasury looks
after the multilateral banks Department
of Defense for our military sales it's a
zoo but it is also reinforced by a
structure of priorities and the monies
farmed out but a ID is certainly the
largest agency by far and the provision
of American official development
assistance abroad but here's the third
point there isn't a whole lot of
discretion in this some of this is tied
up with what's gently called security
the Camp David agreement has spawned a
regular exercise in which Israel and
Egypt received very large portion of our
bilateral assistance there are other
things which are congress insists on
earmarking and boy did they do that with
a vengeance child survival family
planning programs nepal and indonesia
for example its earmarked hiv/aids
global campaign earmarked even
limitations to policing assistance for
example everywhere in big terms and
little terms ism there's a thicket of
conditionality imposed by our
legislature and what we do what are our
goals the next question they'll have
expand as I suggested you a moment ago
and I didn't seem or didn't wish to
appear to be caustic in a way that went
way beyond the comparatively limited
objectives of the Cold War a previous
speaker mentioned a previous error and
aid in which their irrigation specialist
people who knew the backs that you know
all about agronomy knew about the latest
rice seed strains but it was linked in a
way to providing material improvements
to countries that were seen to be
vulnerable to the appeal of marks of
socialism it's a very different error
now in which good governance in the rule
of law democracy and democratization
number of things have come into the
arena for a ID and is made for some very
interesting administrative problems I'm
some of this tends to be worthy but
unfunded mandates democratization for
example a lot of time is spent in how we
can take one item of development
assistance and achieve a range of worthy
objectives improve governance better
management fiscal responsibility trade
capacity improvements so there's a lot
of this effort as well we also have a
very important humanitarian concern and
I think it's a source of pride in our
country that while we have profound
disagreements with the regime that runs
the northern part of the Korean
Peninsula the United States has
continued to ensure that food is not
used as a weapon the president insists
on that in public and private and we
have a situation where we are willing to
ensure that fam does not visit the North
Koreans again successes I think there
are old successes I mean the thing about
our foreign aid program is people find
it difficult to understand that it
really reaches back more than half a
century with the onset of the Cold War
the Marshall Plan there are successes
that you can I think legitimately lay at
the doorstep of a ID including Japan
Korea Taiwan Thailand but of course that
was long ago more recently I think in
the past decade we can in the midst of
an awful lot of skepticism about foreign
assistance feel that for example
economic growth in Mozambique country
visited by floods and really torn apart
by a very bad Civil War following its
anti-colonial struggle has really
reached a point where it's routinely six
and seven percent per annum good
governance in Botswana Eastern European
transitions we're a little bit of money
from a ID targeted on the right type of
policy changes I mean it sounds boring
but it has to do with energy regulation
and the way in which people run public
enterprises a small amount of money is
actually made for some vast improvements
let me just conclude by inviting you to
think about some of the things that are
coming along this later this year like
most bureaucracies it works in reaction
to whatever the next event is usually
it's within a week or the next hour in
this case there a set of conferences
sustainable development conference in
johannesburg toward the end of the year
later on this month financing for
development in monterey president will
be attending what we're doing is trying
to find a way in which we maximize the
of our foreign assistance in an era when
even before September 11th we were
witnessing net negative capital flows
out of the developing world into the
richer world and that's quite apart from
debt forget about the debt principal and
interest beyond that there's been
capital flight so the promise of
globalization which you can argue is a
promise that's been in effect for 50
years the creation of a minute of a
broader middle class the widening of
markets is under threat and it's not
just Argentina that shows some of these
problems where you have a middle class
under threat and we know what history
does with middle classes that feel
vulnerable and impoverished finally I
think you can see a number of signs that
there is likely to be a strong effort
for increased funding of official
development assistance from the United
States notwithstanding various pressures
most important being of course the
counterterrorism effort but I want to
leave you with a thought that this
administration remains pretty
impressively committed to a range of
issues that are addressed by our
assistance that go well beyond the
current an understandable focus with
counterterrorism thank you very much
thank you well that gets us off to a
good start the way our format is has
worked is we have microphones on each
side of the room and people line up and
we take questions for the panel and do
we have some folks that would like to
ask some questions I thought so you know
usually the Chairman takes the
prerogative of asking the first
questions but we run out of time so
rapidly that that that that I'm not
going to do that but I am going to try
to lay down some rules this is not farm
policy karaoke and that is those
microphones are for asking questions and
I'm an Italian boy raised in New York so
I understand the importance of following
rules very precisely father Schiraldi
taught me well so please ask tell us who
you are they ask your question and don't
write an op-ed piece okay
my name is Jim garst and the question
has to do with sanctions mr. fallows
left us hanging by his reference to
South Africa and we'll deal with that
question later so this is an invitation
to deal with that and in the context of
what mr. Birkeland has said about smart
sanctions in the case of South Africa
the sanctions were economic they were
trade sanctions and they were investment
sanctions and they affected the ability
of the economy to sustain sustain itself
on behalf of liberating the majority of
the population who was victimized by
apartheid and that majority in effect
said we are willing to suffer the
problems that go with those sanctions as
a very important part of our struggle
for ending apartheid that is quite in
contrast with smart sanctions which are
aimed at dealing with the people who
caused the problem so I don't know
exactly if mr. Brooklyn would want to
talk about the issue the outcome of
South Africa as the very hard hammer
rather than smart sanctions success
story that I think we all agree I think
that everyone would agree that South
Africa is the only place that sanctions
have had a positive effect and it was a
very special case but if we try to
compare South Africa with Iraq or other
places I don't think that works that way
I think the people the dictatorships if
you want to call it that the small
creeks that run the
countries are the ones we've got to hit
and if we can hit them hard enough maybe
there's the chance to reverse it South
Africa that it wasn't a clique that we
were hitting it was a whole structure as
you well know businessmen and so forth
very hard to design smart sanctions for
South African experience Jim once well
if I could pile on briefly in that
having having a raisin and left the
question I think in a way south africa
may be an exception proving rule just as
Gandhi in India may be an exception
improving the role in both cases they
were gundy success in India was largely
he had a regime he was protesting
against it was Shaima Belen some form
you could embarrass the British in the
long run by saying you're not performing
to this or that standard and the US has
been shamed in various ways and South
Africa while it's hard to think that the
previous regime was really Shaima Belen
some long run it was it wanted to be
seen as part of the Western democratic
world so and that's not a weapon you can
use against you know using a rack or use
another places so I think it was an
exception for that reason yeah let me
just reinforce that by saying I lived I
probably grew up in New Zealand one most
effective weapons against the white
South Africa minority was exclusion of
supporting content and that was a big
shame value yeah economist have studied
at length sank economic sanctions and
political sanctions of various kinds and
a couple of things come through one is
they have been less effective in an era
of globalization rather than more
they've been less effective since 1970
than prior second they are most
effective when you can get everybody to
join in obviously so you don't have an
alternative place to go and finally the
most effective where you are pressuring
a democratic regime so you can embarrass
it and South Africa you know really fit
that model most tightly on this side sir
could you identify yourself and gives
you a question hi my name is David I'm a
journalism student here at Columbia and
I just read a small piece in the talk of
the town in The New Yorker that said
basically that all the aid that we've
been giving in the past couple decades
hasn't really worked that those
nummies that we've given a lot of 82 I
haven't improved a whole lot there's a
lot of talk about smart sanctions is
there a way that we can make aids
smarter to make sure it reached its
target yeah really good question um you
know as a foreign correspondent somebody
who was out I guess for a long time in
wandering the same areas that Jim was
and you know going to east timor a
number of places I've certainly had my
doubts over the years about the utility
of much of what I've seen what's
impressed those is the way in which
actually can be targeted quite well
there's a lot of effort going into
making aid smarter the British are doing
very very interesting work if you care
to look up and we can talk later and
give you some references where there's a
lot of very serious effort going into
better measuring their impact of aid and
also targeting specific projects and far
more worthy sense that said I think
there's a broad sense that if you get
the broad policy environment correct for
example you've got an environment that
has secondary markets and debt and this
type of thing that it means that you
know you can mediate and use capital a
lot better and get better engaged and
into the world economy and I think it's
it's absolutely beyond doubt that
countries which have opted for the
trading advantage and improving their
comparative advantages in the global
trading economy have done better in the
last 50 years and those who opted for
other policy mixes so it's interesting
question and I'd be happy to talk to you
about it later on yes ma'am please my
name is phung I'm a journalist school
student my question goes to mr. fellows
and who said that the most effective way
for us to a child it's not economical
might be like working through
organizations like WTO are you
suggesting that United States should
work multiple letter multilateral
instead of you know bilateral or taking
actions oh its own that is a good
question which gets to something that I
left unclear both in my talk because I
wasn't clear about it in my own mind I
think what I would say with greater
clarity is the US should do both things
at the point I was trying to make is
that the record of almost every other
approach especially sanctions but also
just assuming that that the normal
commercial interaction will solve all
problems that has been so so weak and so
dismal as to make you think that maybe
if you accept the if you if you accept
the belief that you can shape the terms
on which nations and companies interact
as we tried to do in NAFTA as the
Europeans have done in their European
Union then you could shape through WTO
rules you shape evolution in direction
you would like to see the u.s. is so
large that it will inevitably do a lot
of the things it does unilaterally just
because there's certain things that only
the US can do but but it should be able
it shouldn't have an all-or-nothing
choice it should work through the mole
national organizations as effectively as
it can and view them as as view them as
a more promising Avenue than I think
most people do and recognize there'll be
some things are still unilateral one of
the things that's important to recognize
is that economic development is
fundamentally an economic process social
development often accompanies it
economic development cannot be
accomplished without the rule of law we
see in the case of Enron where people
don't follow the rules imagine a whole
economy of bookkeeping like Enron well
you find developing countries where
that's the case a lot of what the WTO is
about is the rule of law is about
standards for the practices businesses
are held to in their countries so as a
way of facilitating greater flows of
Commerce and I think that's in the sense
was that the sense you were talking
about Jim yes good point yes that's what
I meant to say
yes i have it up for advanced WK what
you know is what i do this gentleman
here hello my name is Ralph as X Peace
Corps volunteer I have a few questions
huh oh but first two to say something
about your rule of law which everybody
knows the those who make the Lord's rule
so okay so rule of law is only as good
as the laws you make slavery was legal
so you followed the rule of law but that
wasn't what we have my question now
we're going to guess the correct my my
question is as X Peace Corps volunteer I
know that majority of aid is military
aid and and so if we're trying to build
a better world shouldn't it be peace aid
rather than war aid a very good question
very important question what I'll take
that as a segue to make two points one
is we've we've skied it around the fact
that that I don't know what percentage
you all probably do this the first two
recipients of foreign aid are what
Israel and Egypt Amina so this is not
development aid in the sense we normally
think of it's a whole different category
of international interests which we can
debate on their own term so so the
amount that's going to actual
development aid as opposed to Middle
East security is even smaller than it
seems and and yes as part of the smart
aid measure we should think more about
that the other point would to make
involved the organization that mr.
Birkeland mentioned briefly the
international executive service corps
something in my wife's parents actually
worked in as kind of a Peace Corps for
retired business people and they worked
in Indonesia and Korea and Kenya and
Egypt and I thought I think was very
satisfying for them and had some
tangible results so I think this is a I
give my family's endorsement to this
plan yeah just sorry one quick thing
also Peace Corps volunteer the very last
year of the former ethiopian empire
and the aid there I was involved with a
smallpox eradication program was a very
small the sense of its requirement on
funds but the impact was enormous so I
understand the distinction very well I
could ask on that if I may please who
conducted that the open program it was a
we were linked Ontario it was a World
Health Organization program with Peace
Corps being involved with some of the
more menial tasks thanks Allah I think
we're all about 20 years old we were
scarcely in on a position of
understanding the the epidemiology of it
all but we were vital in making sure
that things happened so you were
volunteers oh yeah i was a volunteer in
peace corps know what we're here sir my
name is ben i'm an undergraduate
economics student here at Columbia my
question is for mr. Birkeland how long
have the Watson Institute the United
Nations been working on smart sanctions
how far away from employing them are we
and would you be able to share an
example of what a smart sanction might
be we've been the Watson Institute has
been working on it for about 33 years
the subject has been a subject of
interest are much longer than that they
have together with the United Nations
and the Swiss government put together a
handbook which I brought with me which
I'll be very happy to leave here which
spells out the rules that the United
Nations should pass so they can quickly
pass a resolution that makes sense in
dealing in bringing in the whole United
Nation apparatus into the subject and
they've also included in that booklet
the rules and laws that each country in
the United Nations should enact in order
to effectuate such smart sanctions when
you look at the book and you figure all
the nations that have to enact these you
know regulatory and legislative
solutions you begin to recognize what a
big problem it is I don't think we will
see really effective smart sanctions for
a long time on the other hand we are
already beginning to see him in the end
my name is Maya I'm professor of
journals and journalists from Republic
of Georgia and I can such kind of
question my country is not country where
United States ever used economical or
even political the sanctions in spite of
some violation of human rights but the
Georgia is a country are receiving a
bite of huge international financial you
know American financial aids but
unfortunately most amount of his money
are not spent on right purpose that
simply contribute for flourishing of
corruption and impedes a development of
economical development and democratic
institutions development in my country
the United States knows that but
unfortunately many Western countries
among them are your countries sorry this
is a rude question but was his fact this
is true but the united states simply
closely say huge amounts billions of
dollars goes what are the wrong right
and the my country my nation has huge
debt depth and least money are not spent
on purpose and how can you explain this
position of your country thank you your
the government go okay welcome to the
United States government well I'll give
all the weasel things first I'm
asia-pacific guy I'm not yet in the
administration
beyond that the questions I you've
raised I think touch on two things which
is corruption in the use of aid and also
I believe there was a reference to debt
relief we are in the middle of some very
interesting debates in Washington about
the whole question and purpose of
development assistance generally you're
looking at this conference in Mexico
going to speak I would watch out for it
because of some interesting things
likely to come from our treasury our
allies and this is a very very important
point to understand particularly the
Germans and the Japanese are very
reluctant to see outright debt relief
right they feel that this sends the
wrong signals and may we may remember
the whole problem of moral hazard which
was talked about so glibly back in the
Asian economic crisis of 97 98 I think
there's something to it debt
rescheduling matters and also outright
debt relief may in fact encourage the
continuation of the wrong policy mix at
least from our perspective as far as the
corrupt use of aid is concerned this is
something that believers all donor
countries the Japanese periodically go
through enormous scandals they're having
one right now over the use of their
official development assistance I would
like to learn more about Georgia so
perhaps we can talk afterwards yes
please if I could comment to this
corruption question if the aid is
directed from the bottom up instead of
through governments down you would avoid
much of the corruption problem and
regrettably most of our aid programs are
these massive programs of military and
what-have-you support and they have to
go through governments but so many of
these countries that have corrupt
governments have a semblance of civil
society and if you can find as you to
hit can in Africa in the aids problem
those little pockets of civil society to
work with then you can work underneath
the government hmm a quick point
remembering a snippet of a briefing book
i was looking at recently in a very
large amount of
American official development assistance
is actually channeled through private
groups in Washington's been one of the
profound changes in the last 15 years so
the NGOs are what known as the pba's
private voluntary organizations have a
great deal to do with a dispersing of
taxpayers funds it's been a very
profound change so I wouldn't want you
to have the notion that this is some
juggernaut run by faceless bureaucrats
of which I'm about to become one I
suppose sir my questions for mr.
Birkeland my name is Dennis miss jerilyn
from baruch college you spoke of
defining carefully the role
multinationals play in case they cannot
contaminate themselves and you also
spoke of the WTO being over-ambitious
could you suggest a role that
multinationals should play and a role
that when it wouldn't mean them
contaminating themselves and do you
believe the WTO is ineffective and can
never be effective you seem critical of
it as an organization I'm less equipped
to talk to these subjects than anybody
up here but the I'll answer try to
answer your question uh I think that the
multinationals have all invaded each
other's territory you can't tell in the
IMF whether they're in the development
business or in the financial crisis
business the World Bank is arguing where
they should be some some of the regional
banks I think about have a better
definition of what they're doing then
the multinationals that we talked about
sorry as the world trade organization is
concerned it has become a target for
everybody who hates globalization it's a
wonderful concept but it's so grand that
it obscures some of the more important
things that are being done like NAFTA
and south american free trade areas but
i mean there's no question it's a
desirable objective and people are
working on it and i hope indeed that we
end up with a regime of free trade
throughout the world
but it's a massive massive thing we'll
take another question on this side we
had taken to hear please sir my name is
Matthias oblem ostrich student School of
International Affairs my question is to
mr. clad since he's the closest to
government to please all yet all the
other ones answer as well my questions
about the very notion of globalization
and trade liberalization since it's
sometimes said by critics that the
globalization its current formal sense
benefits in particular United States and
Europe and not countries in Africa Latin
America whatever not in particular
referring to food and agricultural
subsidies and textiles I want to have
your comment on on that issue all right
briefly because people's eyes will
rapidly glaze over if we gone to two
months minutia I think it would be an
error to see this as something that is
pitched to the advantage of the the
wealthy countries already there have
been a number of very impressive
empirical studies that show that the
trade multiplier effect of countries
that are adjacent to one another in the
Caribbean for example Central America
miracle sewer the very slow to get
started ASEAN free trade area have
brought very important advantages to
countries which have been directing
hitherto most of their trade to distant
metropolitan locales Japan North America
or Western Europe so i think that the
logic of trade expansion and the wealth
multiplying effect is something that you
find in local neighborhoods secondly
agriculture having been brought up
partly in a country which is made
agriculture for good or ill the source
of its wealth it's also very apparent to
us that the unit terms of trade that is
to say you know at any particular point
how much butter you had to produced by
one computer chip the terms of trade
have been against agriculture since the
end of the Second World War it's not the
thing to be involved in if you're
looking for high-end value returned
particularly in foreign trade so
agriculture is a problem that is you
know structural as well as just a matter
of particular lobbies in wealthy
countries preventing an expansion of
agricultural trade and those things have
to be addressed as well to say that if
you simply reduce barriers there's going
to be a sudden influx
wealth is not true when you measure unit
terms of trade and that'd be right
professor Murray's yeah it certainly is
I mean the developed countries have much
to account for when it comes to their
agricultural policies I was chastising
the Canadian embassy from by an MP from
Manitoba yesterday's and it's only
appropriate that you drill on me today
our prom policies don't make a whole lot
of good economic sense and can say the
EU does the same thing is not a good
enough answer because I think we would
do a good enough job of destroying farm
trade without help from the EU we cannot
seem to let go of subsidies and it is a
very unfortunate thing it's also
unfortunate we're not having this forum
in Iowa when we say that however that
said that said if you get your hands on
more farm trade you will not become
wealthier for it the wealthiest country
in the world on a per capita basis in
the 1890s was New Zealand why the high
price of mutton in London but the
reality is that it takes fewer and fewer
people to herd sheep so at any one time
one quarter of the population of New
Zealand is looking for work or employed
in Sydney Australia there's just not
enough work there or hanging out in
universities in New York exactly exactly
next question sir the orange sweater
okay my name is ken caryl emoni my
question is also related to free trade
and actually goes to all the panelists I
think we all agree in the benefits the
free trade can bring to the world into
the u.s. and particularly in terms of
wealth and development but when one look
one looks more carefully at the recent
policy and particularly to the measures
that were adopted some ten days ago on
the steel sector and the protection on
the steel industry I don't really think
that it fosters the adoption of free
trade in the world in general and not
only that I think that it's even a
negative
measure to the US itself in the sense
that in the end the rest of the
population is subsidizing the the steel
sector I have no doubt that the
employments in the steel sector need to
be protected but we should not be
subsidizing industries which are not
competitive my question actually is i
think that probably it would be better
to have the money used to create a job
in job creation programs to to the
people that could be affected in the
industry i would like to know if you
agree with that or not thank you i will
use that i will very briefly answer that
question uses a segue to i want to give
the previous question too i think you'll
find agreement on this panel I suspect
most of the room that this was was not
the wisest policy the Bush
administration could have pursued I say
this is somebody who has in the past
advocated some protectionist measures
for various us industries about the
semi-conductor protection of the 1980s
was good for the u.s. semiconductor
industry but i think this one the
balance with all the negative you
mentioned makes it not a sensible
approach this i use this as a segue to
something i think is what makes the
process of free trade and globalization
fascinating as there's lots of different
levels of the strains intentions to
think about there's something that was
alluded to in the previous question that
sort of the top level of the world in
any given country rising much more
rapidly than anyplace else we see a kind
of winner-take-all phenomenon around the
world which is interesting we see
cultural tensions we don't want every
single aspect of our society to run
purely by market principles there are
other things that we their their places
where tradition and inefficiency matter
and so balancing that is important
there's a kind of transition phenomenon
we see most in Latin America where the
wealth to support large populations
creates own problems and I would submit
there's a particular African question
you know sort of unique to Africa about
why it is is falling behind the rest of
the sort of momentum of this gathering
so I think all of these are interesting
implications which will keep us going
for a long time
jump on there or should I go to the next
question I think it's very very
difficult to have been in Bob's Alex
shoes I mean his brief is and 12 which
is deeply committed is the expansion of
what has been America's mission for most
of the past century that said there are
profoundly important domestic
constituencies and it simply plays dude
I'm not trying to dodge it except to say
that to act as if this constituency has
no power influence in effect and that we
can simply work according to the
abstract precepts of a treatise is not a
feasible option either I think it's also
fair to say that this wasn't Bob's LX
decision to make oh absolutely so I mean
you know Bob is the president's trailer
and sometimes when you're someone's
lawyer you have to send a brief where it
takes you and I would venture just the
following comment also sometimes one
nipson tuck in order to achieve a
broader advantage this has to be seen as
game and process and the broad
disposition of Bob Zoellick of the
present himself is for free trade
sometimes there are things that you want
has to give away on but the temperament
the predisposition is to expand it on
the side sir my question is actually for
a mystery name first oh my name is Jamie
I'm a recent graduate my questions for
mr. Birkeland you mentioned during your
suggestions that the united states
prioritize and classify countries for
receipt of aid I wondered if you'd
expand a little bit more on how that
process might occur and what that would
mean for four countries that might not
be included well first of all I don't
think you would have countries that
would not be included I'm simply saying
that there are comfortable countries
where the bottom-up type of aid works
best economic aid and there are
countries that basically don't have the
infrastructure politically or in any
other way where you're dealing in a
chaotic world in those countries of many
of them in Africa you do your best to
deal with specific problems such as aids
and so forth in furthering our
objectives in the free world however if
you were to focus on countries where you
the middle class has a chance where
there is a structure where there is a
great big gap between the poor and the
rich and where you can find
entrepreneurial spirit then you can
accomplish a great deal in those
countries with economic aid of the sort
i talked about in that category i put
all of eastern europe i would quote
South America where the gaps between the
rich and the poor phenomenal and which
we have totally abandon swear we started
our eight program back in 1962 and where
I think we belong again I think you can
take countries like sri lanka where
indeed this kind of aid can be very
important in developing democratic
institutions in countries where you
don't have a chance of doing that then I
think you have what i call a
humanitarian approach where our
principles carry us but i think to
separate these two out is very important
in the one you can measure your result
in the other it's very hard to measure
your result you just do it ok sir my
name is Bill Stein um what a concern
today is it's open-ended nature to seem
to be continuous through a country and
thinking about that one of the things I
did years ago I worked for one of the
model cities program and key
characteristic at the model cities
program was that it was a thick graph to
a city for seven year period so you knew
you were getting money you knew you were
getting it for a fixed period of time
which has its advantages but it also had
two disadvantages but um I was wondering
could point aid be handled in a similar
way where we would tell a country we're
going to give you aid but it's not going
to be open-ended it's going to be for a
fixed period of time and what kind of
consequences would be for that kind of a
situation yeah I really welcome your
question and I think it really goes to
the root of how we can do well and do
good at the same time much of what one
sees out there as far as recipient
country behavior passing la faire du
jour you know the excitement of a
particular moment is very transient the
having looked at four and eight for a
number of years you know academically
from a distance one sees you know cycles
of interest new buzzwords new
constituencies they come and go and yet
the rupp the problems seem to remain
intractable there was going back to the
50s and interest in smokestack socialism
or import substitution industries and
basic human needs than appropriate
technology then you know I mean you
could we can all think of 15 or 20
examples of these and yet when you go
back out all I see is a sort of chronic
deprivation exacerbated vital in some
ways you know larger human numbers not
that that's a root cause itself but then
that effect one wonders is this
impervious to any directed approach I
think the thing that you phrased is a
very interesting example and there are
and I do invite you to look at a
publication that's coming out of a ID
for this Monterey conference we thought
very hard and I was in there so
ruthlessly saying no I don't believe is
it seems phony I don't believe that this
is a real success story but we came down
to a number of issues and you'll see
your point there again and again there
the commitment year after year very
focused attention of senior
administrators working with civil
ciety most of these things have a an
on-the-ground component and they do
amount to I think examples of where
against the trend that seems to cause us
to be cynical and despair there have
been some very important achievements
please is jareds Colton epidemiologist
for the New York City Health Department
former Peace Corps volunteer trickle up
coordinator one concern that I had as a
Peace Corps volunteer was the idea of
how short term the Peace Corps is two
years and it's not really developed in
developmental terms i believe considered
sustainable development there's a lot of
transition do you feel that and of
course are some benefits to the program
do you feel that the USAID and the NGOs
that you mentioned actually do have
programs that are sustainable I just
missed that last point sorry do you find
that the USAID programs and the NGOs
that you mentioned from the private
sources are sustainable not just
band-aid effects well I do somewhat to
my surprise I find the degree of
commitment astonishing with groups and
that's why I was at some pains to stress
that most of the money does go through
groups in Washington now you can be
cynical about that the sense of those
hovering Beltway bandits there you know
waiting for the next contract and you
know one has to expect a certain degree
of competition but even that is managed
and the degree of commitment is
astonishing and it reinforces this
gentleman's comment about people in
there for the long haul and keeps
bureaucracies honest okay could I make a
brief point this about the Peace Corps
in particular my wife and I work not in
the Peace Corps with something called
the voluntary work camps of Ghana we
were down building school buildings in
Ghana and the early 1970s for a while
living in me in in third-world ish
conditions we've looked up with envy at
the Peace Corps volunteers or than that
next village and my impression is that
neither of the buildings we made in
Ghana nor the classes are being taught
by the Peace Corps had very much lasting
effect on
the gun and condition of life but it had
a big effect on our wives to have spent
the time living there and I think I'm
the Peace Corps volunteers and so I
would be for the Peace Corps in
particular I would justify it if only it
broadened the human perspective the
people who did it the ones that came in
contact with and in their countries yeah
the the Peace Corps is now about 40
years old because kennedy was elected in
1960 and one of the things that we have
seen is that many people were brought
into the kind of work that these
gentlemen do and that i do through the
Peace Corps even though they went to
school and grew up in rather plain
vanilla places two generations ago
everybody that international work went
to Columbia or Harvard or Yale now you
meet people from Southern Illinois at
Carbondale who went to school there nuno
foreign languages graduated with degree
in engineering decided to do the Peace
Corps and came back with a very
different perspective which brought them
into a very different line of work we
have gained a great deal and these
countries have acquired advocates and
understanding as a consequence and that
is an intangible and unmeasurable aspect
of these organizations which I think
that we should never overlook ma'am
you've waited very patiently at that
microphone that's you yes you've been
briefing yes professors do acknowledge
patients from time to time that's fine
my name is svetlana kochi chemist
journalism student here at this cool i'm
from moscow russia and what the person
from Georgia said was not surprising for
me at all because in my country there is
also very skeptical opinion about
foreign aid and humanitarian aid and one
of the popular opinions is that the aid
hasn't been enough if Americans for
instance created some sort of a Marshall
Plan in the early 90s the Russian
economy wouldn't have suffered so much
another opinion is of course corruption
that the aid has not reached it goes in
most cases so if you could it my
question goes to all the panelists if
you could just take a very quick glimpse
and summarize do you think the programs
the eight programs have worked during
the past decade
and the Russian GDP slowly growing now
does America take any credit for it do
you think there's there has been an
important contribution and other any
significant programs planned for the
immediate future so it's actually three
question i would say that up until
certainly very recently it was
impossible to work through the top down
in russia for reasons that everybody
understands on the other hand there is
an Enterprise Fund in Russia and the
International cazares Corps has been
active in Russia and in both cases the
enterprise fund as a 415 million dollar
fund and they've invested in
entrepreneurial activity and small banks
micro lending and so forth and it's
quite unbelievable that they've had a
results without losing all our money and
if indeed you can accomplish that with a
volunteer organization which the
enterprise funds are that's something to
be replicated possibly but indeed we
have had a micro effect in Russia but it
has been in effect i will answer i'm
indirectly about one of the premises of
your question i lost sight of where you
are is that Lana of it back there which
is that something like a Marshall Plan I
spent a lot of time when I was in Asia
studying the effect of US policy on
Japan's recovery what it was and there
was very very little direct us aid the
crucial things from the US from Japan's
point of view were first the land reform
that MacArthur forced on them the the
direct kind of intervention you can do
in a conquered country but you can't do
with Russia you know in those
circumstances second the real recovery
for Japan was when the US fought the
Korean War and bought a lot of supplies
in Japan it wasn't aid it was a wartime
boom and third was the sort of open
market for imports after that where the
US was the main consumer for Japan's
imports and all especially the latter is
still there does the US is a very open
market as the Chinese know well and my
conclusion was the main reason that
Japan was able to recover was not aid
but the pre-existing industrial
structure they built up over the last 60
or 80 years that could be sort of revved
up again and i think the russian
situation is more complicated and
difficult one than the the marshall plan
and japan recovery your question madam
forces us to ask ourselves some
difficult questions about our
expectations at the end of the Cold War
there is a sense I think in America that
people are sort of naturally market
minded that that it would be easy to
take public assets and somehow you know
go through a Robert's Rules of Order
privatization of them so that everyone
would turn out being a stakeholder I
think there was a lack of understanding
and how badly damaged the fabric of
Russian public life had become under the
relentless and terrible effect of
totalitarian socialism led by a
dictatorship so these things were things
that I think we've led to some other
facile expectations that shock therapy
we may remember that term was likely to
deliver and all it delivered was penury
in some ways because of the way in which
public assets were simply handed over to
whatever group people had preferential
access to them beyond that though I
think it's a mistake to assume the
United States was really in position to
predetermine the outcome of the Russian
economy and to that extent we were not
the victors in the way that mr. fallows
has just described our unique position
in Japan in Japan the Japanese had
adopted after the Miche restoration to
German civil code and had essentially a
Western legal structure contract law of
bankruptcy law ownership Laura all the
rest and essentially the German and
Japanese economies were organized for
the war in very similar ways and it was
a matter of disassembling that the
apparatus for focusing a market economy
on military advantage it was a much
smaller much smaller activity than would
be involved in even if the industrial
assets were present you can't find
someone who understands how to be a
judge in Russia and in a western-type
context because they don't have Western
law if sir
Mike Wasserman in contrast to mr.
fallows very heartbreaking comment about
Ghana and the work that he did which
made he and his wife feel good but god
of today is you know got a really is
heartbreaking story and you know it
wasn't exactly my point but go ahead but
in contrast another country which is a
very small country in a rather poor
country here's a quote from last month
senator joseph lieberman made a major
foreign policy speech and here's this
one brief quote since 1999 jordan has
sharply cut tariffs and other trade
barriers launched an economic
integration project with israel and
completed a full free trade agreement
the united states the results are
impressive in the past two years alone
jordan's exports the united states have
risen tenfold and more than 25,000 jobs
have been created 25,000 jobs a lot for
a tiny country like jordan so we're not
seeing the positive effects of the
governmental aid we're not seeing the
positive effects even in large scale of
the Peace Corps and these other NGO and
private don't we feel if we really care
about God in these other countries that
real genuine export increases would be
there their best interest I think that
we're all and we agree then finding ways
to have to to make market growth
possible in societies where that is
where it is possible and finding ways to
remove the barriers to keep it from
being so yes so we agree and I would be
surprised if Jordans export improvement
or entirely a market phenomenon given
the other things going on that part of
the world but more power to them just
like you reinforce it's very interesting
intervention and to say that your
taxpayer dollars through a ID went
toward enabling that important
transformation there was official
development assistance from the United
States going to Jordan to help them
prepare the structure to basically
engage with the international economy
and advice went through to talk about
the Free Trade Agreement the United
States I mean all that was done with Oda
and it's an interesting example of where
you can say well let's have five
projects which incredibly time-consuming
involve a lot of work I'm not saying
that
on tourism doesn't work but in addition
if you come in at that level you get it
right historical moments there you've
got political will and all the other
things that need to be there as well and
expanding global economy a market niche
and so on that that can have a
tremendous transformational impact as
well all right we have six minutes to go
oh good I always one comment at make the
executive a square was very active in
Jordan wherever you can find an
entrepreneur you have a chance and where
you can't find an entrepreneur you have
a problem and it's about that simple in
terms of eight programs thank you we
have three question is still standing we
have six minutes I'm going to ask each
of you to be really concise yes we'll
take the three questions together and
give the panel a chance to respond to
those questions and make a wrap-up
comments ok my name is Javed Khan and
I'm a graduate of Columbia Business
School and I have a more philosophical
question what is the ultimate goal of
American aid and sanctions are we trying
to transform the world in the American
image like making an economy of each
country like America or is is going to
serve our national interest which is
totally different from the objectives of
those countries thank you sir we'd like
to ask your question very briefly Oh
oldest blucas twice or tired i would
like to also mention that i'm a member
of one of the I think two generations
which can say that when I was born the
world population was that they record
higher level now it's three times higher
which leads me to the question and I
hope you did not touch on this but i
hope you might address it broader namely
is the development and a devoted to it
sustainable and the second question is
about aid it was mentioned that peace
corps definitely helps Americans America
receives also other kinds of aid for
example the highest
the large percentage of the best brains
come to America we our imports are
financed by life somewhat by broad and
so on and so on how do these two kinds
of a balance one going out from America
and one coming in thank you thank you
sir yes my name is thomas hollywood i'm
a former volunteer in South America and
Africa and now I'm a international
cornea for a volunteer organization here
in the city and basically my question
revolves around the amount of forney
that's given the 12 billion dollars that
was thrown out there I was wondering how
you might see that and future is that
going to fluctuate you see any prospects
of that increasing and then also I guess
because of the administration the
mission state of the union address is
there any direct foreign I'm excuse me
financial assistance going to be
provided to private or faith-based
volunteer organizations can we start out
with you John would that be all right
well I think maybe you go ahead you
first jected you would mr. Clyde like to
go first very quickly some of the
question you asked faith-based
organizations obviously something that's
close to the presents heart there are
some interesting matters being discussed
right now which could see some
involvement in those directions but I it
stress and I'm not dodging it I've just
in transition and I'm not really sort of
up to speed but I'll give you my card
afterwards and we can you know stay in
touch and I can give you some more
direct information about that the figure
as I suggested to you early is facing
some interesting pressures on the hill
as well to see an augmentation of
overall resources which might lift it
beyond I'm not at liberty to say
anything more about that because their
budget discussions but we're certainly
not in a position where there's a lot of
pressure to push it down if I can react
to the other two things and then leave
it at that or do you want to do okay the
philosophical goal it seems to me and
this is where my own interests you know
getting foreign aid birth back in the
mothership so to speak of our overall
security objectives which is a world in
which demonstrably people who are
wealthier lettuce larger middle classes
with a better system of governance a
more participatory system make war less
frequently and I think that it's a
security question fundamentally I'm not
saying it's only but that's my and
that's many of our core positions and I
think it's an absolute
ansible one finally the question of
development sustainability it's very
interesting that question I hope it
wasn't just a Malthusian question which
is more human numbers there's some very
obvious things when people become
wealthier family size is reduced it's
known as a demographic transition again
and again we see it in places that do
successfully take off and I don't see
any reason why we wouldn't see a
plateauing of human numbers as far as
the sustainability of development my
past work has been partly in the energy
field and there's some fascinating
developments there it isn't going to be
easy there's an immense pressure but I
think key core concepts like this take
an enormous amount of time to permeate
through but I believe that the
transformation and attitude toward for
example large mega capital intensive
projects is enormous just in the last 15
or 20 years with regard to the goals I
fully agree with you yet if we could get
a civil society in every one of the
countries that we talked about we would
be a much more secure nation and the
world would be much more peaceable
therefore if one says the objective is
to develop civil societies free rights
of human beings then these aid programs
have a real meaning and I say
particularly they have a real meaning
when they're dealing at the ground level
even though it's not so easily too broad
easy to broadcast it on the radio out of
television this the thing I would like
to leave as a message behind is we need
more aid money secondly we ought to have
two separate budgets that have a budget
is proactive that we determine and then
the rest of it is more or less thrust
upon us by circumstance or by Congress
but there ought to be a separate part of
our eight budget that's sacrosanct
and it's aimed at economic development
at the bottom level I have two new news
items before answering these questions
one is I recognize that my friend James
clad Adelman officially appointed has
actually spiritually become part of the
administration he said that faith-based
initiatives were quote close to the
president's heart now those of us in the
civilian population might talk about
bush or the bush administration when
you're working for the government you
talk about the president the president's
hard the president's view so we have
just just don't tell my daughter
investor just looked into this yeah it's
on TV she'll never hear so that was
that's one news item second a news I'm
to me the big surprise of this evenings
discussion is there's been no apparent
descent to the idea that sanctions
simply don't work when you think of how
much of our government's policy now is
based on sanctions it's quite a
surprising conclusion at least least it
to me on the on that the points raising
the questions what is the ultimate goal
explicitly it is not to make other
countries into America and I think this
is important point to make because
partly there's a naive assumption in
many Americans that this is sort of the
climax of human ambition people come
here from around the world so they may
all want to be Americans I think that's
not what it should be there's a possible
American process there's a possible
long-term conflict between what we may
want my other country may want in that
the u.s. believes that small d democracy
is good for everyone and that could
ultimately lead to some conclusion but
there's a lot of intermediate things we
can do we believe in less violence less
infant death less starvation and that
can keep us going for a very long time
should development is it sustainable I
think a sufficient ambition is to make
it more sustainable through different
energy policies James cloud and I both
spent Our early years in Southern
California which is a lot less polluted
than it used to be and then it's more
it's over built but it's less polluted
finally the flow of aid around the world
a reason to have eight around the world
so the US has to sort of skim off west
of the talent it's a glory of America
that we can absorb talented people from
around the world many of them the room
this evening but it probably would be
better if they didn't feel so compelled
to
the US so that's an ambition for our a
22 well thank you very much and I thank
all of you and we join me in thanking
our panel